[Music]
during the commercial break i was asking
about your your beautiful uh wedding
ring
we were talking about your your husband
yes i got married this year yeah good
for you congratulations
and your husband your husband
is dutch is that right dutch yes okay
he's from
the netherlands the netherlands yeah
amsterdam now do you
is your plan then for you know is he
teaching
say your your daughter how to he hasn't
been teaching her how to speak dutch but
he teaches her a lot of dutch
songs and things like that and she has
little dutch books
but it's harder for him to to speak to
her in dutch and then with me and then i
feel isola it's more about me feeling
isolated
right and them being able to talk about
me and me not knowing what they said
so i said absolutely no dutch in the
house except for like she does know a
lot of dutch songs
are dutch like are they it must be
adorable to hear a little girl sing a
dutch
it's so sweet and there's this one
beautiful song i don't know the name
even if i did i couldn't pronounce it so
it doesn't matter redundant
um and it's about these two sisters
um named constance and matilda and it's
this beautiful song and martin was
telling me
about what it meant and these two
sisters live together
and they have a canary that goes cheap
cheap cheap and
um they drink tea and they do all these
wonderful things and then one of their
other sisters dies and leaves them a
bunch of nightgowns
this isn't a children's this isn't a
children's song i don't i don't know
they all sound like children songs to me
so they leave the nightgowns now the
problem is there aren't enough night
counts to share
between the two of them so one day when
constance is out
taking a walk matilda poisons her coffee
but then goes like i wonder if there's
enough poison in that
takes a sip of it she dies the other
sister comes home is like
this is so sad but now i get all the
nightgowns
there you go i don't understand that how
that's a chill no don't applaud that's
horrible that's the worst
that's the worst children's song i've
ever heard i don't know
even a children's song but no it's by
sound garden i think yes i think it is
but it's like you know constance matilda
and it's really pretty and it's crazy
i don't know what i was doing just
making random noises that's what i think
dutch sounds like anyway i'm always what
does it sound like
i don't i couldn't even do it if i tried
you know what it sounds like andy
there's lots of hong kong
dutch people at all it's just i can't
say it yeah make fun of it they've got
it good
yes they're not going to be but they're
so tall they've got all those chocolates
and dams you know what i'm
when i'm you know what's an and is it
here's would be my concern
is that if your husband's from europe
sometimes i get irritated with the way
they do christmas
you know i mean i think in america we've
got it right lots of commercialism
lots of toys you know yeah that's how it
should be done
and then they do things like you go to
bed in the morning there's a walnut on
your pillow
right but it's dipped in a little bit of
apricot juice cause
papa santa came
you know and then you're like well what
else happens then we all nap and then
more walnuts
yes but in holland they do have
schwarzepeet
who's the little elf um assistant of
sinterklaas which is cynthia klaus
yeah no it's santa claus but listen
and if you're if you misbehave he'll
beat you with sticks and put you in a
bag and take you to spain
economy is rough there right now yeah i
think that was i just think i find it
very fascinating whenever i hear about
you know
when i talk to friends who spend uh
christmas
in in europe they don't understand us no
it's always like we put your shoe in the
oven
because we play a trick on little booty
party
yeah terrible terrible they got to get
with the program lots of toys
commercialism
lots alcohol yeah um